we're on 76 in the figure below a B Line
a B is a tangent is tangent to circle Oh
at Point a fair enough point a secant BD
intersects circle Oh at points C and D
right this is secant BD secant beauty
and seek it just means it intersects the
point of two points it's not tangent a
tangent intersects the circle is exactly
one point all right so you can't be the
inner circle intersects the circle at
points C and D measure of arc AC is
equal to 70 degrees so the measure of
arc AC this is 70 degrees okay and the
measure of Arc CD is equal to 110
degrees that's equal to 110 degrees so
what do they want us to figure out what
is a measure of ABC so what is a B ABC
so what is this angle that's what they
want us to figure out they want us to
figure out this right here that angle
let's see what we can do here so there's
a couple of ways to think about it well
there's there's one way well if you look
at the if you look at this is 70 this is
110 right so if you add them this whole
arc going for all the way around that's
actually what it's 70 + 110 that's 180
degrees so it's actually perfectly half
way around the circle so actually from A
to D is actually a diameter of the
circle how do I know that because it
goes all the way around the circle it's
180 degrees that the arc length is 180
degrees so we can draw let me draw a
diameter line I don't so this thing is
drawn to scale so a 2 D is actually a
diameter of the circle and we know that
because that's 180 degrees the combined
arc length right there and we know that
this line is tangent at point a this
line is tangent at Point a so that has
to be a a right angle right when you're
when you're tangent at point a that
means your tangent to the radius at that
point fair enough so now let's see what
we could figure out we know that this
arc length is seventy is there any way
is there any way to figure out what this
angle right here is because if you know
this angle
no this is 90 then we could figure out
that angle and this is something that
you should just learn about about what
we call them inscribed angles in a
circle this is an inscribed angle
because the vertex touches on one of the
sides of the circle so the an inscribed
angle and this is just something good to
memorize and you could play around with
to get a little bit more intuition about
it is equal to half of the arc length
that it intersects so this inscribed
angle intersects an arc length of 70
degrees right so this is 35 degrees it's
35 degrees and that's just something
good to know that this is going to be
half of whatever this arc length is
right now we can figure out X because X
plus 30x plus 35 + 90 is equal to 180 so
let's see you get X plus 35 is equal to
90 x is equal to what X is equal to 90
minus 35 is 60 is 55 which is choice C
now there's another way you can do this
and this is another interesting thing
about about lines that intersect in
circles is that this angle measure right
here if it's sitting outside of the
circle and well I think there might be
once we're sitting inside the circle
later on but if it's sitting outside of
the circle it's equal to one-half the
difference of the arc measures that it
intersects so example it intersects this
arc measure of 70 and it also has this
arc measure right here right when it
hits the circle with an intersex at 70
degrees and when it exits the circle has
this arc measure this arc measure we
already figured out is 180 degrees
because that's 180 degrees so you know
that this angle right here you could say
that X is equal to one-half the
difference of these two are measures and
that we can do that because X is outside
of the circle if X was inside the circle
then X would be one half the sum of the
two measures so let's what's the
difference it's 180 minus 70 so that's
equal to one
half times 1 10 so that is equal to 55
again so it's nice to see that math
works around works correctly no matter
how you do the problem problem 77 in the
circle shown below the measure of Arc PR
PR is 140 degrees sure enough the
measure of angle r PQ is 50 degrees okay
that's 50 degrees what is the measure of
Arc PQ what is this arc right there so
we could use what we learned in the last
problem that 50 degrees is an inscribed
angle right this is an inscribed angle
so it's going to be half of the arc
length half of the arc length measured
in degrees or arc angle I guess you can
say of the arc that it intercepts so
this is 50 then this arc measure is
going to be a hundred degrees right so
what we're trying to figure out this arc
measure right here it's whatever you
really have left over right a whole
circle has three let's call this X so we
know that x + 100 + 140 well that goes
all the way around the circle right
that's going to be equal to 360 degrees
c you have x + 240 is equal to 360
degrees subtract 240 from both sides you
get x is equal to 120 degrees choice D
problem 78 the vertices of triangle ABC
are ok a is 2 comma 1 B is 3 comma 4 and
C is 1 comma 3 if triangle ABC is
translated one unit down so one unit
down means that we're subtracting 1 from
the wise right and three units to the
left so that means you're subtracting 3
from the x's to create triangle d e f
what are the coordinates of the vertices
of d e f so let's see we have a a was 2
comma 1 2 comma 1 and
going to be translated to let me let me
write it neater a is 2 comma 1 and
that's going to be translated to point D
and what do they say one unit down 100
down means the Y decreases by 1 so the y
coordinate is going to be decrease that
by one you get zero and three years to
the left so that means you decrease the
x coordinate by 3 so 2 minus 3 is
negative 1 negative 1 actually just
looking at the choices we're already
done all right this is D is the only
choice that had a negative one comma 0
but let's look at the other ones maybe
somehow they change the lettering or
something let's see point B point B was
3 comma 4 3 comma 4 so what did we do
with X we said three to the left so that
becomes D this comes point E so you take
this three years to the left three
you're subtracting 3 from there so that
becomes a zero if you take the
y-coordinate one unit down that becomes
a three so E is 0-3 so that's still
consistent with this so let's just make
sure that the F works so C was 1 comma 3
if we take three away right we shifted
to the left by three so that's taking
the three away from the x-coordinate so
that's minus two and then if you're
shifting the y-coordinate down one
that's taking one from it so that's two
so f is minus 22 and so d was definitely
the answer problem 79 if triangle ABC is
rotated 180 degrees about the origin
what are the coordinates of a prime okay
so we're going to we're going to rotate
this thing 180 degrees and essentially i
mean we could worry about all the
coordinates but they just want to know
where a prime is so this is going to
have so wherever a sitz after we've
rotated it right so let's think about it
a little bit let's think about it a
little bit when we've rotated the see
this is going to be the new see it's
going to be right there and then the new
a so let's see the bee bee is going to
be
when you rotate it I just want to make
sure I'm doing this right this is almost
like a this is a visualization problem
if you go for know if you go this is
[ __ ] this is four to the right and up
three right so if you were to rotate it
around if you were to rotate let's say
this this little arrow I drew with the
four if I were to rotate that 180
degrees I just want to make sure I do it
right then that's going to be for this
way right that's going to be one two
three going to be for this way so you're
going to be that point and then you're
going to go instead of three up you're
going to go three down just going to go
three down three down so that's where a
prime is going to be right at that point
right there and that's the point might
that's the point minus five comma minus
four that's minus five comma minus four
and that's our answer but let's let's
figure out all of the other points so be
you go up to and to the right up three
and to the right two so that you would
go from the new see you would go you
would go let me make sure right about
the origin right so the new see I'm just
trying to make sure I'm right the new
see would go the newbie you'd go three
down three down to the left ok be there
so that's the new be right and so that
looks right that's what the triangle is
going to look like this is B Prime this
is a prime this is C Prime all right
this is a new triangle when you rotate
it 180 degrees that was that was a
challenging visualization problem but
the key thing is just to keep
visualizing going up going around 180
degrees so minus 5 comma comma minus 4
that's choice a for a prime problem 80
problem 80 let me switch to a better
color trapezoid ABCD below below is to
be translated to trapezoid a prime B
prime C prime D prime by the following
motion rule ok what will be the
coordinates of vertex
c prime okay so that's all we have to
worry about we're at sea and we're going
to translate it to some c prime what are
the coordinates of c c is x is equal to
5 and y is equal to 1 so what's c prime
going to be equal to C prime we'll just
use this mapping rule you add 3 to the X
that's going to be 8 and you subtract 4
from the y so 81 minus 4 is minus 38
minus 3 and that's choice D and we're
all done we're all done with the entire
California Standards geometry test and
frankly you know I started off grumbling
a little bit because I thought they were
getting a little bit too obsessed with
the terminology but overall I think this
is a pretty good test and if you if you
understood every problem on this on this
on this exam I think you know your your
geometry pretty well anyway see you in
the next video although this is the last
in the geometry in this geometry series